[Music]
earlier this week i did something
unusual i issued a challenge to our
viewers okay and this is my challenge i
said if you can find any mistakes or
errors on our show
send us a video
telling us about it confront me with
this mistake and let's see if it really
was a mistake right so far i've crushed
all critics
with powerful robot i'm turning into
charlie sheen
with powerful rebuttals
i've crushed them they're all trolls uh
[Applause]
so far i've crushed all critics and i
tell you something and i've done it with
very strong arguments today i understand
we have yet another challenger so let's
play it
hi coco this is nicole last night i was
watching your show and you did a skit um
with the machete guy
um and there was this drink um
tie your blood
yeah here's a picture
that looks like fruit punch
you wouldn't be able to like see right
through it
so yeah that was like a huge error
um
you should really like
fix that in the future or whatever sorry
[Applause]
huge error
do you hear the way she talked to me i
know it's ridiculous it's insane
question the master eh
well i have definitive proof that there
was real tiger blood in that bottle
here's the man that procured that tiger
blood our prop master bill tall all
right
so
so bill what do you have to say
hey nicole this is uh this is not fruit
juice it's real tiger's blood
i got it from this guy right here
very good bill now tell nicole why the
tiger is standing up rigid attached to a
base
rigger motors
bill tell everybody thank you bill
well well
looks like i'm three for three
but the challenge still stands if you
think you've spotted an error on our
show report it at
teamcoco.com
haha i found an error
and send us a link to your video
explanation and let's see if you've got
what it takes to make chump meat out of
the master very nice let's take a little
break